Hawes is located in a remote part of northern
England: the Yorkshire Dales. But this village
is anything but sleepy. That's in large part
due to councilor John Blackie. When the local
post office, gas station, library and bus
service were to be shut down, he helped turn
them into community-run operations. He plans
to combat the effects of Brexit the same way.
"You know we've managed to be this self-reliant
capital, as they call us elsewhere. And we'll
hang on to as many services as we can."
For example the community-run gas station.
On this day, they're drawing visitors to Hawes
with low gasoline prices. And who sets these
prices? Councilor John Blackie, of course:
"He's a whirlwind. He´s a dynamo, I think.
I've lived in the area for 15, 16 years, and
really anything good that´s been done, has
come out of John and his efforts."
The almost seventy-year-old advocates for
affordable housing; is honorary chairman of
the bus company; executive chair of the gas
station; and subpostmaster at Hawes post office.
He's also happy to provide info on the bus
schedule.
In Hawes, it's still possible to borrow library
books or cash a check. That used to be a given
throughout the Yorkshire region, until budget
cuts led to the loss of many services. Blackie
fears Brexit will only make things worse:
"We don't have a grand master plan. We deal
with issues as they arrive. But we deal with
them very quickly. And if there is community
solution - there won´t always be - but if
there is, we will find it and we will implement
it."
Just like they did in the early 1990s when
the cheese dairy was slated to shut down.
Blackie helped save the Wensleydale Creamery
-- together with David Hartley, who is now
its managing director. The employees simply
took over the business. And today, the creamery
employs over 200 people and exports cheese
around the globe.
"He's been a champion of employment in the
area. In a lot of the Dales, yes, we rely
on tourism, we rely on agriculture. But a
lot of it is about proper employment for local
people."
Still, young families are leaving Hawes.
Maintaining the village's infrastructure is
becoming increasingly difficult. And it's
just been announced that the only bank branch
will close for good.
"I thought they might carry on a bit longer."
"The last thing you want are shops and premises
to be empty. Because when shops and premises
are empty, people look at the place, it starts
to look tired and dowdy, and not thriving.
And therefore people don't come."
"But we'll carry on in Hawes, and we´ll give
our example to other communities. Because
if we can do it, they can do it. We are not
taking 'no' for an answer, I can assure you.
Am I right?"
"Absolutely!"
The Little White Bus is an example of just
how contagious John Blackie's enthusiasm can
be. He's recruited 60 volunteer drivers to
chauffeur tourists, and residents who can
no longer drive themselves. They go on outings:
for instance to enjoy tea and sandwiches in
a neighboring village.
Residents of Hawes all agree that John Blackie
is one of a kind...and irreplaceable.
"I keep looking. I've got to come up with
somebody soon. There will soon time to hang
up my laptop. I haven´t found anybody yet.
But I keep living in hope. I'm an optimist."
Which the people of Hawes appreciate.